- You might have seen
the picture going around
Twitter of the dude who
put candy corn on pizza.
When I saw it, I called it literally the
worst thing on the internet.
Naturally, people tweeted me back
saying they wanted to try it and that it's
probably pretty good.
So, that's what we're doing today.
Taste testing candy corn pizza.
(dramatic piano music)
- [Logan] Candy corn hater,
this is to see if you
change your mind on candy corn.
- This isn't gonna--
- [Logan] Candy corn
lover, this is to see if it
changes your mind.
- This is gonna make me hate it more.
- This is gonna make
me dislike it as well,
I don't wanna, I love it so much.
It's like walking in on
your parents having sex.
- It looks disgusting.
- No.
Canceled.
Cursed image.
Eye bleach.
- Well, seeing as I've
never been a candy corn fan,
seeing it melted on top
of something that I love
is very devastating to me.
- I'm feeling a little
nauseated, not gonna lie,
because I know what's about to happen.
- The texture of the
candy corn right now is
actually pretty interesting, it's looking
a little waxy.
- It does look very waxy.
- It still looks like candy corn,
but it's (clicks tongue) mmmm.
- Like candles.
- Ready?
- Alright, here, cheers.
- Cheers.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- Alright.
- Ahh, mm hmm.
- Hey, it's not bad.
(upbeat music)
- Meh.
- This is worse than actual candy corn.
- It's uh,
it's not horrible.
- It's not terrible.
It's not terrible.
- I still don't like candy corn.
- It starts out really bad.
Then it's mostly just pizza, so.
- It just tastes like sweet pizza.
Like if you put honey on this
pizza it would taste the same.
- It's a little much,
it tastes like something
that 12 year old me would really like.
But I'm older now, I'm a man.
And my tastes have gotten sophisticated.
- If you like sweet and savory you might,
you might be into this.
- Don't do this.
I don't understand why you
would have to do this, but.
- I like it.
- Why take something good away?
Why ruin a good thing like pizza?
Just--
- They didn't ruin it!
I think it enhanced it
in a non-traditional way.
- Candy corn pizza is the worst thing
to have happened to humanity.
- Candy corn pizza is unnecessary.
- You know what, folks,
candy corn pizza's not bad.
It's not the worst, it's not the best.
Don't mix the two, it's not advised.
Eat the pizza first, then
enjoy your candy corn.
Like a normal human being.
- Candy corn pizza is not as
bad as you would think it is.
- Great marketing campaign.
Candy corn pizza!
It's not as bad as you think it is.
- Oh, God.
I hate, I hate America right now.
I don't, I don't at all.
I love it, love this. . .